what's the most common question someone
asked you when they learn your triplet
uh
usually
all the time all the time and if we've
hooked up with the same chick
[Music]
we brought together six sets of triplets
we are triplets we're triplets we are
triplets we are triplets we are triplets
one set is a liar if the group discovers
who the liars are they will split a cash
prize
if the liars survive
they'll win the entire prize
who is the odd one out
[Music]
triplet party yeah
i will say not quite the we got two two
girls one guy not quite there
the matching set oh that's not fair to
them i'm just pointing it out so do we
have any identical triplets here i feel
like you guys are we're actually
fraternal
we do get
if you can believe that we are actually
identical yes wow okay i need to we got
different hairstyles i'm gonna say the
hair my throat it's like the before
middle and after picture
different different hairlines how did
your mom and dad used to differentiate
between you two when you were younger
our moms our mom could differentiate
they used to wear different shirts with
our names on it only they would wear
different shirts not you no we all did
yeah yeah shawn had a different lump in
his head when he was yeah
they dropped him going oh so they're
like this is
and i feel like we're older so then when
you get a little older you you
differentiate a little more your hair
your hair is not going to look that wavy
for long
smiles we got like different haircuts
our haircut's like our main thing like
you guys look like you belong to a
vampire high pass
that's what it looks like now we'll say
you two look similar different
hairstyles and then you in the back a
little different you guys identical or
fraternal
paternal yeah okay you have the same
cheeks though
which parent rocks the bandana in your
household did you guys just do that on
your way we just thought i'm the one who
started it and then she started copying
me okay so who's baby a b and cc
[Music]
okay i noticed that there's a short
amount of time but you i noticed that
you're just a little bit taller but
you're a little bit more quieter too i'm
always very shy
she's been speaking for her
[Music]
they had like the same vibe and i feel
like when you're triplets and your
siblings you kind of like differentiate
each other as much as you can being so
similar in siblings is kind of annoying
they seemed nervous and they didn't
really coordinate themselves on speaking
[Music]
it was disappointing but not surprising
when we were eliminated a lot of people
don't believe us when we say that we're
triplets because we don't look exactly
alike and i knew that would be something
that we'd have to face going into this i
have a question
who starts all the fights
yeah i feel like we don't get in fights
often definitely more when we were
younger we kind of grew out of it i feel
like we get along a lot better now i
think we're like really close that
middle girl really threw me off as she
was talking i was just looking at the
two in the back like
those two look very similar and i don't
know if she's like a sister in it i feel
like every single time one of us are
fighting it's either me and him or me
and him he's also instigators like if
you tell him to stop it doesn't end
until he also finds the joke on funny
yeah
it's definitely them too definitely not
the peacemaker
what's the most common question someone
asked you when they learned your triplet
uh
usually
all the time
[Music]
and if we've hooked up with the same
chick
people just come and be like who's got
the bigger dick and we always tell them
to just find out for yourselves you know
obviously but also like people ask if we
like hooked up with the same chick at
the same time which is like none of us
have taken a trip to paris yeah that's
what we're saying very
dis very sweet guys very
i was saying an eiffel tower yeah that's
what i was saying they got it they don't
need the business but you can't really
ask boob sizes no no no
they always ask if we're identical i
know or did you used to fight a lot when
you were a kid yeah do you share clothes
or they're just like how are you wearing
clothes as girls
i am surprised like for three girls all
the same age you guys seemed perfectly
amicable like it didn't seem like you
just fought much i feel like out of all
the sets here you guys look the most
different i agree our friends told us
that we were going to get voted off
because they're like you guys look like
friends yeah you in the middle look like
a friend how does it feel when you guys
are apart we've never been apart for
more than 24 hours
that'll change
we were together since the womb all
throughout high school and our first
time separating was going to college i
yeah i moved out no offense to like my
parents but i missed my sisters like
more than anything so we were separated
for 24 hours and we couldn't
couldn't sleep we all woke up at the
same time
whoa
you too yes definitely look dramatically
different
you guys look like you guys could be
twins but you're the odd one now gotcha
gotcha we're fraternal so do you guys
write a lot as like sisters i fight with
her way more than a fight with you i bet
i'll play with her with her get over it
within a few minutes yeah there was a
lot of repeating in that group like oh
yeah because we're fraternal how come
you two get along so well i don't know
just i think it's just the fact that my
sister and i share a lot of friends so
it's like
kind of this dynamic where you're always
together and with him i'm not with him
i'm not with him as often we have the
same friends yeah and i'm assuming you
you just said that you guys have so much
how is it for you like being like the
guy in the group versus like three we're
still you know triplets so i still feel
like i'm as close to like each one of
them as they are i get along with her
like a lot more i don't know why i get
along with her friends more like i don't
get really along with her friends but
they have the same friends don't fail we
have some of the same friends
in high school that was like the peak of
all our friends together in college we
all have different majors they're the
same school though and university yeah
what universities csun well like what
were the chances that all three of them
were going to csun so i thought maybe
those were friends that met in college
wait there's actually one thing i want
to point out is you guys i don't know i
caught you saying moms you were like oh
my mom's and then you caught yourself
you're like oh my mom our moms our mom
could differentiate like why would he he
did he did slip up there but it's just
mom and dad and yeah well sure that's
what you would say what's your mom and
dad's name caught on the car
okay
[Music]
since the other sister had curly hair
and the boy had curly hair it was super
weird that the shorter girl straightened
her hair because then it kind of gave
the vibe that she was like maybe a half
sibling or a friend
and in my opinion they were all the same
looking so they just found the easy way
out voted out the people that look
different
raise your hand if you think that the
mole is still in the box and you would
like to continue playing the game
starting now for every time all of you
vote out someone that is not the mole
the total prize money will be reduced i
have a question
or more
telepathy we finish each other's
sentences a lot i wanted to hear that
from them if they would do it three to
one see your favorite word three two one
oh i didn't say a word i don't even know
i think we like we talk
like crazy it's like when you have a
really good best friend and you can like
look across the room be like you know
what i'm thinking it's like yeah yeah i
got you for like an event you don't want
to be like a party or someone's house or
something we all feel the same urge to
leave like in this yeah
yeah
yeah i i just i'm going to call it out i
just think you're younger you're shorter
you're smaller
of the family
well he's the rental litter too
he just looks like a divorce dad he
can't help it
but i think the versions looked like the
exact same like i i felt like i knew
they were triplets very confidently off
the beginning especially because like us
three being three guy triplets and then
being three guy triplets everything they
said like we related to i feel like we
were not suspicious of the sternolos or
the benavidez's not at all they looked i
i mean the sternolos look like us if we
were like a boy band and didn't have any
muscle on us whatsoever
i'm just gonna put you on the spot like
on the count of three i'm gonna say a
question you'll have to say at the same
time what's your grandma's name which
one which is on your mom's side one two
three
sorry
there's a there's a disturbance in
but i the force
can like tell at this point like i don't
know you guys are safe in my opinion
it's this side for sure saying the
scariest thing is like we all look alike
so at least i didn't raise my hand and i
asked if the mole was still a circle so
i don't know who's feeling suspiciously
i did i raised my hand because i think
it's i think it's them i raised my hand
because of them i think i think it's
done can you guys describe your mom
no like personality wise
when she was raising this or now yeah
she's she's literally two different
people yeah growing up she was a sweet
catholic lady she always raised us to be
like very like school was important
religion was important yeah and then now
she's kind of like all right do your own
shauna rum springer is what we call yeah
she gets her out of the house she
doesn't care anymore she was the good
cop to my dad's bad cop yes cool okay
what about i still feel like you're
still in high school can i see the heels
because it's significantly that's a big
heel like he's a little shorter
also i hate to say it hate to say it but
it looks like you two got ready today
we're like oh we're gonna go to like the
same place cause you're wearing like the
same thing that you have like this nice
cool shirt
your personality you gotta know it's
covering the heel too it looks like
you're trying to hide something no she's
literally she's she we're not hiding
she's literally shorter their facial
features are very different like their
noses are kind of different shapes their
eyes are kind of different shapes i
don't know what color everyone's
toothbrush is growing up because like i
feel like you have to have a different
color toothbrush so that way you don't
like accidentally use your siblings to
brush i mean yeah we just have different
colors but we change the colors all the
time but she is blue i don't know i like
pink
i don't know blue red green green we had
two different bathrooms i shared a
bathroom with my older brother and then
they shared a bathroom together
because we actually different bathrooms
there's four boys we had four bedrooms a
bathroom on one side of the whole
bathroom on the other side i feel like
you could be the older brother like
you're the 15 months older brother i
i will concede he was he does look older
but she also does look much younger do
you think that's an easy thing for me to
admit that i'm the older one
in high school well yeah you got giant
giant heels okay and you've been taking
the lead on a lot of these things what's
your what would a younger person do that
which i would say no somebody who's
overcomp or
and overcompensation okay once i pointed
out the shoes she started coming at me
heavy like i feel like they were coming
at us anyways we were all kind of like
subtly going at each other and sean that
was not flirting by the way
well look for their instagram in the bio
where'd you guys become friends that was
literally what i was going to ask for
[Music]
it's okay we knew this would happen what
do you mean by that
they knew it would happen because it was
true
raise your hand if you think that the
mole is still in the box and you would
like to continue playing the game
if the lights turn green that means
you're voted out the mole and you win if
the lights turn red that means that the
mole is still in the box and you lose
[Music]
[Applause]
easy i knew it easy i knew that i could
sniff it out from the beginning i knew
it i knew it put it there then the molds
please step forward in three two one
no twins no no no twins we were always
asked if we were triplets
two years two years yeah no way
we were very much raised like triplets
whatever happens with your other friends
you know that you always have your
sisters and i think that that's
definitely important to us we're each
other's best friends i don't know what i
i do without these two to be honest
you're not really ever alone so that was
always cool yeah when i have kids i hope
i have twins or something because i
could never be an only child agreed
i knew some of the same people because i
transferred them oh my gosh you guys i'm
literally
your story is very olivia what were you
gonna get
i'm getting a stack baby
that's a w
that's a w
i don't want to mess up the stack this
is the best day ever
that's so funny
you were the one that said that fight a
lot huh who cleans these out